now it was an extraordinary Verdict by a
coroner that promises to change social
media and do a huge amount to protect
children from online harm the coroner
said 14 year old Molly Russell died from
an act of self-harm while suffering from
depression and the negative effects of
online content in other words social
media was partly to blame for Molly's
death it was a crucial victory for Ian
Russell her father who had fought a long
battle to hear those words after the
inquest he said this
we should not be sitting here this
should not happen because it does not
need to happen
um
but we told this story in the hope that
change
would come about I hope
that the world
will be safer the digital world
particularly will be a safer place to
inhabit
and the final
thing I want to say
is thank you Molly
for being my daughter
a hugely emotional moment but are things
really going to change or are millions
of children still at grave risk well Ian
Russell is here with me now thank you
for coming in and you fought an
extraordinary battle
um to get this inquest verdict a very
significant verdict but six weeks on do
you think things really will change
that's such a such an important question
mark
um I think they have to change they have
to change for the sake of our young
people
um there's still an awful lot of harmful
content available online very easily
available and in fact
um there was a survey published by
Samaritans only last week uh survey
commissioned by um the Samaritans and
Saint by Swansea University
um that said over three quarters of
young people had come across self-harm
content by the time they were 14 and of
of that number of people uh 83 percent
um didn't go searching for that content
it was pushed to them by the by the
platform's algorithms so they they were
confronted with content harmful content
that they didn't even want to see so so
for viewers who don't know
um what kind of content was Molly
exposed to
it's very hard because as a broadcaster
you're not allowed to show a lot of the
content Molly uh was exposed to
newspapers can't print it you can't
broadcast it and yet it's readily
available on platforms that officially
have a lower age limit of 13.
but this is material almost encouraging
yeah there's material that normalizes
self-harm there's material
um that shows graphic self-harm wounds
and that's very disturbing to see
um quite often uh quite gory quite
bloody and not pleasant to see but then
there's material that
um encourages sort of depressive
thinking uh a sense of worthlessness
which I think is actually the more
dangerous of the two sorts of material
they're both horrible
but that sense that Morley had as we
know because she left us some notes that
she felt hopeless and worthless and she
felt a burden to other people when in
fact it was completely the opposite is
the material that encouraged that sense
in her that said simply uh things a
little cartoon drawing I say this got
often the one that sticks in my mind is
a cartoon drawing of a sad looking uh
girl that just said who would love a
suicidal girl
and it wasn't just that one post which
on its own might not be too harmful or
dangerous but Molly saw hundreds if not
thousands of those posts in the last
weeks and months of her life and this
stuff is still out there
um the chief executive of nspcc said the
other day more than a month after the
coroner concluded social media
contributed to the death of Molly the
sites our children use
are still Awash with dangerous self-harm
and suicide content because there are no
consequences for industry uh in action
so
um what are the chances and I know this
Online safety bill is going through the
process but it is being delayed and it
looks as if it might be watered down how
worried are you about that
that is a massive worry and it's not
just a worry for me sadly I I've met too
many other parents in very similar
circumstances the the official stats in
the UK show that there are on average
four school-aged children that die by
suicide every week that's four mollies
four families like wine four sets of
friends who've lost someone so the age
of self-regulation has failed and the
only thing that will change that is
government regulation to to to make the
tech platforms put their house in order
the third reading of this bill which has
been well considered there was public
consultation there was a joint scrutiny
committee that looked at the bill and
made sure that it was as good as
possible before it went to the House of
Commons the third reading of that bill
in the Commons should have happened in
July but because of the political
turmoil in the government at the time
change of leadership it was delayed
should have come back in early November
it's been delayed again and we are
waiting for a date when that will happen
and the problem is that that bill has to
get through the commons and then the
House of Lords have to have enough time
to scrutinize it because it should be
scrutinized in both change Chambers
that's how this thing works in our
country and so that normal process of of
uh uh scrutiny by the House of Lords is
it it needs to have enough time to do
its job right and I mean it's going very
slowly and it is being watered down
particularly in terms of this harmful
but legal content and they're now
talking about allowing it for adults but
not for children now that then relies on
this whole idea of a proper age
verification so I mean how concerned are
you that the tech companies will in a
sense be led off the hook
um
I am concerned that there's a
possibility that tech companies will be
led off the hook
and that horrifies me because I know
what I've lived through and I don't want
anyone else to have to live through what
I've lived through and as the coroner
found social media played a part in
Molly's death uh so this has to stop
it's really important that protections
for Children online are at the highest
possible levels we protect ourselves in
our offline world we have speed limits
on motorways and we have seat belts in
cars and airbags
um we acknowledge the dangers and we
protect ourselves we need to start doing
that online as well so if this doesn't
get through in this parliamentary term
would you feel personally let down would
you say would you think the government
had let you down I would think the
government has let not just me down
but every parent in this country down if
the Online safety bill in a meaningful
way isn't given enough time to be
debated properly and to be on the
statute books so that oftcom the
regulator who are waiting in the wings
ready to do this they're keen and eager
they've already got staff working on how
they're going to regulate this they're
ready to go this just needs to get a
move on get through Parliament so that
children and young people in particular
can be protected online and the stats
are mind-numbing more than two-thirds
British children age five to Fifteen
using social media you you know hinted
at this one third of seeing upsetting
content of some sort I mean these are
huge numbers and just to be clear that
Molly's behavior in the real world Ian
gave you new no indication that she was
inhabiting this Bleak online world that
you knew nothing about there was no
indication that there was any uh mental
health problems with Mom beforehand she
was a she contributed
um in a normal way to our family life
she was really happy she she may have
spent a little bit more time in her room
as her older sisters had done before her
she was a teenager she may she did come
to me and say I I'd like to give up
horse riding which with withdrawing from
Hobbies is a sign to look out for but
she didn't just say I'm bored with it
she said I want to give up horse riding
because I plateaued and I think by
having a rest and going back to it it
would be better for me there was always
a forward-looking thing the weekend
before she died she was looking forward
to her birthday which uh was on the 21st
of November she would have been 20 this
year she was looking forward to her 15th
birthday she'd written a birthday list
she bought
um presents for her sisters who also had
November birthdays she was so
forward-looking and so positive it was a
bolt from the blue it was a horror story
for us so I mean so there are so many
questions that you have
that may never be answered
I think that's always the case after a
suicide and one of the other things I
think the the Online safety bill has to
talk about is the process by which the
authorities not necessarily the family
but the authorities can gain data we
struggle during the inquest process
which is one of the reasons it took so
long we had a very supportive coroner
who who did everything within his power
to get data from the platform so that we
could look into Molly's viewing habits
it took ages for them to give that data
to his inquest that's easier now or
would it be easier under an online
safety bill it needs to be and there
needs to be measures in the bill that
there's almost a sort of automatic
process where
um a coroner or a law of official law
enforcement request when they are
received the tech companies
automatically preserve and deliver the
data to the authorities in the same way
that a police officer can come to your
house with a search warrant and search
your premises they need the search
warrant but they can do that the same
thing again has to happen in the online
world now finally uh Ian there will be
other mollies out there there will be
other
um youngsters in a similar situation do
you have any advice what would your
advice be to parents who
maybe listening to this or know what
happened and are deeply worry what would
your advice be to those parents it's
it's really hard because you have to
keep up a Channel of communication you
have to keep that dialogue going between
the generations so that the younger
members of the family feel happy enough
to talk about their problems empowered
enough to talk about their problems to
their parents and that's a big Challenge
and if you're concerned about someone
whether you're a parent or a friend or
you're someone who is struggling the
most important thing is to know that
there is help and you need to seek out
trusted support don't look in the darker
places on the internet you can you can
text mrf for the Molly Rose Foundation
context mrf to 85258 that's a text Line
run by shout who who look after anyone
that contacts them in so many different
ways but that's a very good place to go
for example if you're looking for help
okay in look my that goes up to you and
thank you very much for what you're
doing thank you